okay well from hollywood to vegas beauty
queens are taking the stage again for a
national pageant and this one's
not for all the single ladies okay we're
bringing so vegas back
celebrating women's history month with
an inside look on becoming mrs
nevada america and hopefully on march
27th
mrs america now live from convention
hall in atlantic city
the miss america pageant the lights
the excitement the entertainment the
stage itself
it's it's historic it's iconic
and that's why our state pageant uh
costume is that of the showgirl from
show girls to beauty queens
vegas has no shortage of glitz glam
feathers and crowns and whether you're a
miss
or mrs you can roll the dice this is the
premier pageant for married women
taking her first walk as mrs nevada
america 2020
ashley tesoro mom actress
model and philanthropist ashley tesoro
is ready to take the stage for the mrs
america
national pageant naturally doing the mrs
nevada america pageant
was the perfect opportunity for me
because not only do we get to be on
stage and
do all this glamour and beauty and
fashion but we are also
workers in our community for doing
amazing outreach
and doing benevolent works and working
with charities and so for me
it was the perfect fit i have a
seven-year-old i have a five-year-old i
have a two-year-old
so naturally i'm you know working all
the time
being a mother being a wife and i really
think that the pageant adds that element
of doing something just for you
and whether you win or you don't win
it's really not about that it's about
the journey
but we want to win so what does that
take
welcome to beauty queen boot camp take
your right foot
and step forward do this slowly as
you're looking over your shoulder
sure you need poise and poses i'm
working on that
but what you don't need is perfection
it's not about the
perfect image it's really about being
the best version of yourself
and i really believe that the paget
brings that out of every woman that gets
involved
and if you want to walk the walk you got
to talk the talk
interview is very important so when
you're presenting yourself to the judges
it's super important so you really want
to
work with somebody that knows how to
formulate
help you formulate these amazing answers
that are authentic to you but that will
translate to the judges so you know you
don't want to be too long-winded you
want to be able to be concise
that's a tip learned from former beauty
queen and state director of the pageant
jackie mckenna so get in your position
look at your judges back and forth
she'll definitely have you ready for the
judges
well we get five judges from across
the country they are from all walks of
life so they'll have different
perspectives
they look for the all-rounded woman who
can
represent everybody from across the
state it doesn't
matter if you are six feet tall or
411 we've had queens from all across
you know the the range of of looks
ethnicities walks of life
doctors pilots homemakers hairdressers
or hosts and reporters jackie says the
mrs nevada america pageant
is all about what you bring to the table
and if that comes from the heart
well then the crown is for you
you got your crown on lindsay oh well oh
thank you man you look
like a pageant queen about that i'll
leave that to ashley i'll leave that to
ashley oh my gosh
i mean you can catch ashley i know we'll
chat about it we'll chat about it
you can catch ashley at the live on the
live stream of the mrs america national
pageant
on the 27th and you can actually help
her automatically move into the top 15
of the competition by voting in the
fabulous
face section at mrsamerica.com
that was fun